she had no way of getting in the pool
unless he put her in the pool to cover
up what he did Casey Anthony opening up
like never before we the jury find the
defendant not guilty over a decade after
what was called the trial of the century
oh yes I will definitely give her credit
for being one of the best Liars I've
ever seen
I just need someone to be willing to
listen she's speaking out in a new
docu-series Casey Anthony where the
truth lies you're gonna ask that
question what happened to Kaylee in 2008
Casey's two-year-old daughter Kaylee was
reported missing her body was later
discovered near her family's Florida
home Casey was charged with Kaylee's
death her defense team claimed Kaylee
had accidentally drowned in Casey's
father George Anthony disposed of her
body manipulation after manipulation
after manipulation
[Music]
but somehow he got cleared by law
enforcement from day one on stand at the
trials George denied having any
knowledge of Kaylee drowning and said he
had nothing to do with the disposal of
her body he also denied Casey's claims
he ever abused her which also come up in
the new Doc he didn't inquire to where I
was that day because he knew
getting an inquire to where Kaylee was
because he was the only one who knew
where she was in the series Casey as she
did in the trial alleges that her father
could have been involved she had no way
of getting in the pool
there was nothing for her to have
shimmied up to me there's no way of
explaining that unless he put her in the
pool to cover up what he did
[Music]
so if he decided to call the police they
would have looked at it as a drowning
and not actually examined her body a lot
of the docu-series features Casey
reflecting on her regrets from when
Kaylee was still alive I wish every day
I would have said something to somebody
at some point
maybe things would be different
probably not